my name is chelsea holmes i am a prison
matchmaker
and i live in panama city florida i
started years ago working for a wrongful
convictions group and writing inmates
that were incarcerated and it blossomed
into a business i'm trying to see my
baby you know bryce is my soulmate i
feel like i hit the jackpot with this
guy
i'm a prison matchmaker
tell me about your career path and what
got you specifically into
prison matchmaking so it really just
stemmed from writing inmates and where
they would ask me hey can you find
you know my cellie find him a pen pal
and i would post them on social media
once i posted some of these guys on
social media they would have thousands
of women
writing them so they go from no pen pals
to like a thousand and i thought okay
well there might be something to this so
i continued to post new people every day
and it blossomed into a prison
matchmaking business was this a surprise
to you that so many people wanted to
date people in the prison system yes and
no no because i myself you know have a
thing for bad boys that are incarcerated
so i kind of knew where most of them
were coming from but really when the
business took off was during covet
because so many people were stuck at
home with nothing to do
wanting to find that connection with
someone so they're on tick tock all day
long scrolling they come across my page
and they see
thousands of eligible bachelors looking
for love okay so i want to get into the
specifics of the business what is your
business called it's called prison love
and friendship where do you find your
clients and then where do you find your
pool of prisoners who you wind up
setting up with your clients
um i have contacts at a lot of the
prisons you know throughout the us okay
um and i'm known in a lot of the prisons
as the prison matchmaker hey you need
help finding a pen pal or
a girlfriend call chelsea do you roughly
know how many clients you have at the
moment on the outside there's about 20.
on the inside i have thousands i have
you know upwards of five or six thousand
men and women incarcerated you'd think
that the person on the outside would pay
for it but the inmate pays for it and
forgive my ignorance here how does an
inmate who lives in a prison how do they
have money how do they have access to
bank accounts and and wiring you money
and whatnot so most of them work in
prison they have jobs whether it be in
the kitchen or
you know maybe they do work on the yard
or they work in the visiting room so
most of them do have money and the ones
that don't have their families to
support them so i get a lot of family
payments it's a very unorthodox approach
to love because people who are
incarcerated they don't have traditional
access to a phone or you can't
necessarily go on dates that you would
in a traditional relationship why
specifically
prison inmates with the prison inmates
you know their schedule and they work
around yours so my day with with the a
prison relationship would be
an email from them in the morning hey
how you're doing you know i hope you
have a great day and then maybe an
afternoon email and a night email you
know once or twice a week you have video
dates where you spend 30 minutes to an
hour you know like this video chatting
with them and getting to know them and
being silly and maybe you're eating
fancy and you show them what you made
when you start out this way even on the
outside a long distance relationship
you're building that mental connection
first with the person right you're not
as you're not jumping into something
physical right off the bat it's all
mental now don't get me wrong
it's hard it can be hard when you want
that person physically but then you know
you go to visits go visit them and
that way spend time with them in person
it's on a state-by-state basis each
state's different most of them use a
system
where you can communicate face-to-face
with the person through video um video
chat but it's all through the prison
system so everything is seen and
regulated
every video visit scene so you still
have to be
you know conscious to what you're
putting out there with your organization
you make the rules and i'm curious where
do you draw the lines when it comes to
someone's criminal history or past i go
by no crimes against women or kids
period so you can't have any shady stuff
against a woman or a kid
and be on my site okay and then what
kind of clients are we going to see on
the show prisoner of love clients that
are going to be on the show are going to
be drug charges maybe possession or
intent to distribute
there might be some small robbery
charges as well what is your track
record i mean do you have marriages do
you have babies on on the books i do
have marriages on the books no babies
yet okay um
i actually have been asked by two
different couples to to marry them
um this fall so i think that's pretty
sweet i think i'm gonna do it do you
have any ground rules for your club is
there anything where it's like if i see
this you're automatically out if the guy
jumps in there the guy being the one in
prison jumps in there and he's like i
love you within a few weeks or
seems to be just way more into the
relationship than you are that's a red
flag the biggest red flag is when they
ask for money and it happens recently
like um devon has been asking for money
if this is a new relationship and you're
just meeting and getting to know this
person and building this relationship
there's no reason
for them to be asking you for money they
have family or they have a job
you know it's the same thing on the
street if i was dating a new guy on the
street he said hey can you give me a
hundred dollars
no
no i don't think so so what's the what's
the difference i assume with what you do
for a living there's a handful of
misconceptions that come along with it
what is the biggest misconception and
can you kind of set the record straight
i think the biggest misconception people
have is they're in prison they don't
deserve anyone people and their
negativity like on you know my social
media is like why would you want to
write him you know he's in for robbery
or he's in for drugs
he made a mistake he's he's paying for
it
right now
everyone deserves love i'm hoping that
with the show this is going to open a
lot of eyes for a lot of people and
maybe they'll
think differently about prison
relationships and they'll also be
willing to you know maybe give that
person that's fresh out of prison a
chance i can't wait to snuggle i want to
be alone i need to be in love i'm really
excited to see you as a part of
discovery plus new show prisoner of love
uh what was it about this opportunity
that you were like i want to put my
personal life out there for the world to
see i think um as you'll see in in
season one my love lot nobody's love
life is perfect especially when you're
dating somebody incarcerated it's hard
and there's lots of ups and downs but
i'm glad i put it out there because it's
going to give people a real like okay so
yes not only does she match people she's
also struggling herself that's huge
oh i'm with the sunshine
michael is a guy that i was dating in
season one and he was in for armed
robbery michael came to me um to be
posted for pen pals so
i i posted him and then he kept calling
me even after he was pretty post you
know messaging me and sending me emails
all the time and i was going through a
breakup already and so it just it works
you know the conversations with him
everything flowed together and i was
like wait a minute why am i trying to
match myself with him or am i trying to
match others with him
because he's really good-looking
for me yes and i'm completely attracted
to this man how do you nurture that
relationship when you can't go to the
movies together as a couple or go to
dinner together as a couple we would
have date night so they um there's all
sorts of you know creative fun things
would watch the same movie at the same
time you know you just have to find ways
to make it special and where do you two
stand today
you have to watch it and find out what
is the one prisoner of love moment
that fans watching cannot miss there
might be a wedding wow that's all i'm
gonna say i'm just waiting for him to
walk out the doors
i know you're a really proud mom how old
are your kids what do they think of what
you do for a living my kids are 13 and
22. so you'll actually see my son um he
is best friends with one of the kids
that i matched bray so he's on season
one as well and he's supportive in me
he wants me to do what makes me happy
and is you know makes me successful my
daughter too she i think her seeing me
interact and always talking about these
inmates and their charges and what
they're doing to better themselves is
giving her a different point of view i
tried to get my son to date somebody in
the prison system
great girl
he he went back to his ex you know how
the ex is always leaner do you think you
will ultimately end up with someone from
the prison system
i do i mean how how close are we
no i have no rings
but chelsea you did
get a tattoo if i'm not mistaken i did
today we are getting tattoos of each
other's names what why did you do that i
got michael's name on my back he has my
name around his ankle all right i'm
going to take that as a good sign that
things are going well between chelsea
and michael you just have to wait and
see
[Music]